welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of Rick and
Morty season 7 episode 2 The Jerk trap
let's break down all the Easter eggs
animation details and inside jokes that
you might have missed the episode opens
with Jerry asking Rick to help him out
with a rake situation Jerry I guess
thinks Jean borrowed his rake and Jean
said no too fast Rick just tosses Jerry
a blaster to handle it showing just how
loyal Rick is to the guy he just partied
hard with last episode an attempt to
Stage an intervention on Mr booby butth
hole though who knows whether they
intended this episode to come directly
after 701 in the continuity Rick is fine
ignoring Jer until he says all that
brain and you just waste it hold up are
you going to kill me I was born crying
and pissing myself just like you then I
became the smartest man in the universe
and do I get credit no I get to check my
brain privilege I mean Rick's not wrong
we know that there are Rick variants
like slow Rick AK tall Morty as well as
dupus Rick they aren't really marked by
their intelligence Rick wasn't born
smart he's just extremely stubborn and
determined and egocentric he just has to
always be right and that's what drives
him not like any kind of natural
intelligence it's also fun to take note
of the actual tinkering Rick is doing
like he unscrews the tip of a blaster
which is the same part as the node on
the kitchen colander that he uses as a
headpiece for the Mind Swap and then he
cranks down another colander that he had
ready to go with only three nodes to
screw this tip into and he just kind of
tapes on a wire to the side as always
Rick's tinkering is oddly specific but
it also shows how he economically
recycles his parts around a different
appliances on Rick's shelf is actually a
jar containing a few green crystals
that's a commodity that ends up playing
a role in the rest of the episode to
prove his point Rick plans to swap their
minds not to swap their brains within
their bodies because Rick notes that
their brains and all their physical body
parts are Hardware so this is not a
Freaky Friday scenario though it kind of
is but the episode's title is a
reference to The Parent Trap a 1961
Disney Haley Mills movie turned 1998 n
Zan remake you know where twins get
together yeah yeah yeah after they were
separated at Birth to get their parents
back together and one of my favorite
internet memes is the theory that guy
Fetti and Paul Hollywood from the Great
British making show are two twins who
were parent trapped we get blue energy
for Rick's mind and green energy for for
Jerry's mind these colors correspond to
their shirt colors now after the swap
the first thing Rick's mind does in
Jerry's body is just SOB uncontrollably
stagger over to the gun that Jerry left
on the shelf and off himself with it
like The Thing Rick couldn't process is
just how much existential dread and
sheer Panic Jerry lives on with a
regular bases and is his normal
meanwhile Jerry's mind and Rick's brain
and body just adjusts really just to the
physical aspects of Rick like his knees
wobble and then he activates Rick's go
go gadget cybernetic implants that we've
seen alliver his body throughout the
series that includes a targeting eye
blaster in his left arm and in his right
index finger just several smaller tools
because he's right-handed and he would
need most Tools in this finger it's his
most useful finger though according to
past scans of his upgrades the targeting
eye is supposed to be in a different eye
though later in the episode it is back
to the correct eye so maybe he just has
these in bows now he takes one step and
the rocket boots ignite and toss them
around the garage causing him to bleed
out Rick's computer scans the brain
matter but can't tell the Smith parts
from the Sanchez Parts notice how the
DNA Helix has change for each person as
does the numerical code at the bottom
right one of them is 2466 7658 and the
other is is 5846 4297 Morty has been
nabbed by some gangsters and taken to
Crime town there were some Mafia aliens
in the bad of acid episode these guys
might be part of the same Syndicate head
mafios so's name is Chuck Lee it says
Morty is a kid who hangs with the Rick
Sanchez calling him the chaotic neutral
sci-fi guy little detail I love Chuck
Le's pinky fingernail is longer you know
so that he can use it to snort powder
after the surgery Rick and Jerry end up
all shuffled up both of them a mix of
Jerry and Rick and I like how when
they're mad at the other they call the
other Jerry so only the Jerry aspects in
each other are capable of screwing up
now for Simplicity sake in this
breakdown I will refer to the mostly
Rick body as Rick and the mostly Jerry
body as Jerry but let's just all accept
that both of them are the same fused
identity for this episode for most of it
like one thing I've noticed about myself
as a YouTuber is my brain actually does
have a form of Dyslexia where it's kind
of just hard for me to process Freaky
Friday scenarios and mind swap
storylines like I get it on a basic
level but it just kind of takes me half
a second to remember that the face
doesn't match the mind it's just kind of
hard for me to keep up with the humor as
it's happen happening in real time I
know I know it's stupid but like that's
also why like sometimes I call nebula
gamor and Gamora nebula in videos sorry
to all of you viewing despite how much
you love new rock stars you have a host
who is like broken in these weird ways
Rick's heads scan opens another
cybernetic in his shoulder which appears
to just be a golden egg beater Chuck
slee calls Rick to apologize and Jerry
and Rick fight over who gets to take
charge of the scenario tell me where you
are no you tell them where they are like
Liam niss do not pretend to explain Liam
niss to me a reference of course to the
movie Taken but what I love about this
episode is that once Rick and Jerry have
merged it's easy to spot all the shared
Rick characteristics at first but
they're also both Jerry and so the pop
culture references are just kind of a
little too basic for Rick like he says
R2-D2 they bring up Cone Heads they
reference taken by the actor name like
Liam niss that's how Jerry references
pop culture not Rick and just to further
mix things up Jerry pushes up his hair
to be spiky like Rick's and pushes down
Rick's Hair to be flat like Jerry's they
refuse to let the other fully drive the
car and drive straight into Chuck Le's
penous where Chuck Le says Morty is
happy as a milkshake because this day is
the first he's ever heard of the concept
of Milkshakes Jerry says I'm Rick that's
my son-in-law and we're all a little
gay and I like how in the overt talking
one of them says hey it's a spectrum
because yeah the Kinsey scale is nothing
to fear my friends in the background of
this Penthouse is wall art that kind of
looks like a body that was encased in
carbonite or cement Rick says Morty get
in the car twice once for each five
additional briefcases this owes
us stop doing this terrible impression
of me which might be a metod to the
discourse they knew they'd be having
over Ian Cardone and Harry beld in
taking over the roles check out last
week's breakdown because I go into why I
think Ian Cardone is actually doing a
really good job it's just he's getting
closer to the season 1 version of Rick
before later Seasons when Rick's voice
devolved into kind of like a looser
grumbly voice now since this place is
Crim Town everyone in the restaurant
down below is an armed criminal Rick
activates his cone head implant and we
learned that Rick and Jerry share this
cone head phase or maybe this was like
the Jerry aspects connecting with each
other it's referencing the 70s SNL
sketch that they made into a 1993 movie
this is when Wayne's World just ended up
being a huge hit and in the '90s they
turned like so many random SNL sketches
into movies like sure we got Way's World
2 but we also got like night of the
rockberry we got Superstar Mary kther
Gallagher movie we had Al Franken
Stewart saves the universe we had the
ladies man get a movie none of these
made that much money but we got movies
for all of them but you know what I
think Jerry and Rick are right to point
out that the cast of cone heads is great
I mean Dan akroy Jane curtain Michael
mcken Sinbad David Spade Chris Farley
it's not that great of a movie but you
could imagine some of the comedy nerds
the Rick and Morty Riders room
respecting it as they shoot their way
through one alien with a glowing
eyepiece gets shot between the eyes and
I just like how the tech stops glowing
when it gets shot there's an older
female alien that they shoot then Rick
Dives on Jerry to save him from an
attack from the glaive this is from the
1983 film crawl craw was also referenced
in season 4 episode never rcking Morty
that's a story Train episode oh one shot
energy huh I think I'll try
[Applause]
it
so what does one shot's Focus shoe
[Music]
do
eternity
wa so uh one shot really is all you need
begin your transformation with oneshot
energy today by going to oneshot
energy.com
new rock stars for 10% off your order
over all of this we hear the White
Stripes track we're going to be friends
that played over the opening credits of
Napoleon Dynamite Rick uses his conee
head to burst out of Chuck Le's chest
just like the xenomorph chest burster
and alien when they get back one of the
drive-through bags has an M logo which
kind of reminds me of evil Morty's M
logo that he draped over the Citadel
Rick and Jerry spent all night rigging
up a mind un shuffler in style whereas
before Rick's slap dash one was just two
unmatching crappy chairs and kitchen
canders the one they make now has
matching cushioned Hightech chairs
they're remember the rake that Jean took
and they rig up x-ray goggles to peer
into his house we see some food warming
in the microwave photos on his wall show
him in on his graduation day him fishing
him with his dog we see inene skeleton
how it fills with milk and then a rake
in the garage it's handle made of beach
wood and it looks like there's like a
stuffed bear in a hamper there Beth asks
who is talking to me right now mostly my
dad or mostly my husband I've been on
that website gross Beth wakes up the
next morning and knocks on the kids'
doors kids breakfast and school if we
don't at least pretend they matter
everything falls apart this is another
great meta line because while Rick and
Morty is pretty much a total sci-fi
Adventure Show at this point it often
circles back to like family meals Morty
in school it makes no sense to see this
but the show needs these grounded
components for the balance because if it
was just all sci-fi we'd have nothing to
go home to and it wouldn't be as funny
Rick and Morty left a note for the
family that's mostly just an explanation
for why Rick and Jerry felt they didn't
need to leave a note but the note they
left for Jean is a lot longer it is two
pieces of paper taped together and I'm
assuming it's a really long list list of
MCC platitudes about how they forgive
him and just want him to live his life
and be happy Jerry and Rick team up on
an adventure stealing some crystals
through this wealthy space Colony I like
how the wide shot shows that a
skyscrapers but also a secondary
District at a 90° angle that drops down
beneath the rest of it and goes right up
to the edge of the bubble maybe a
Spaceport the two friends are now
wearing stupid Hawaiian shirts and flee
with crystals in a double bag the music
of all this giving off some Magnum PI
Vibes they crash through a pain of glass
can't believe a dying kid would wish for
a window such a hilariously dumb joke I
think the dying kid just wanted a room
with a view not for them to construct a
window in his interior room wall they
leave calling cards of burgers stuffed
in the mouths of their enemies this is
from all the drive-through stops that
they made kind of reminds me of the
stupid calling card of the wet Bandits
turn the sticky bandits in the Home
Alone movies instead of an RV they drive
a space car that is a full multi-story
house they celebrate by doing Howard
Dean screams that's referencing that
excited Yelp that 2004 Democratic
primary candidate Howard Dean did at a
rally that the media went crazy with and
it ended up tanking his his
campaign which looking back was such a
stupid non-s Scandal to in a campaign
Howard Dean probably would have beaten
George W bush in the general election he
was like the first national candidate to
really mobilize the internet as a
campaign tool and later as DNC chair he
had an awesome 50 state strategy that
Obama really had to thank for his
victory in 2008 no now don't get on me
for being political I'm talking about
like a full generation ago in political
history I'm not saying who to vote for
now 2004 was like 12 political Paradigm
shifts ago no one's talking about the
Swift boat anymore so don't get mad
the robot bartender serves P coladas and
repeats 5:00 somewhere referencing the
song by Alan Jackson and the late great
Jimmy Buffett who fun fact was my
father's college roommate and in Jimmy
Buffett's book a pirate looks at 50 he
credited my dad Phil for buying them
cheeseburgers that they ate on the beach
during a road trip to Key West which
Jimmy said in this book quote sounds
like a familiar song doesn't it yes the
Voss family Legend is that my dad bought
the cheeseburgers and Paradise and I
miss Jimmy Buffett we lost him this year
and I love my dad who has lived like a
forest gum life he has like tied into
history in so many crazy ways chuckle
returns whole filled stomach just
bandaged up despite his intra still
being on Mor you when they got back to
Earth he says what's the problem kid
conad got your tongue he is so stupid he
does not know what any Earth thing is
and speaking of Florida and Jimmy
Buffett stuff Jerry and Rick flee on a
fan booat in a swamp away from some
redneck Pirates I was thinking this is
reminiscent of Miami Vice but I don't
know this might be like the low country
of Louisiana too because it kind of
seems like there's like a Louisiana
accent there you guys could have done
that the whole time to rescue the family
they merge into jerii a kind of
quadruped mation it uses Rick's butt but
also Jerry's legs coming through his
green polo shirt sleeves as the frontal
legs and then Jerry gave his torso an
eight pack for no reason and then while
this creature fights the goons for no
reason he beats his chest like an ape I
really think these mafiosos might be
connected to the bat of acid gangsters
because they bring it all back to this
chemical plant with similar Vats of acid
but in this case everything's flammable
Chuck Lee coughs up blood and Jerry ke
says chuckle this is a good death this
is what the operative says to one of his
kills during the opening scene of
Serenity this is a good death on the
long ride home summer asked to turn on
the radio or a podcast do you not hear
the Symphony of Adams dying in
space um no I do love the moments they
just let Summer be a teenage girl back
home summer asks you can't actually be
leaving right like the crows thing the
crows are a call back to forgetting sck
Marshall in season 5 when Rick replac
Morty with two crows that he trains and
then the following episode transitions
into Rick Moray Jack show jerii steps on
a rake Allah the classic Simpson's
running gag or Sideshow Bob is
constantly stepping on rakes but this is
what snaps their two independent selves
out of it killing the Fus Consciousness
and while Jerry just screams non
sensibly like Rick did in Jerry's body
in the cold open Rick uses every breath
to scream that a 30-year-old version of
himself is still trapped inside kind of
reminding us of that season 3 episode
when a young version of Rick would
Express his trapped inner self's honest
thoughts whenever he sang or did did
something creative help me help me I'm
going to die tny RI The White Stripes
song returns and we can see the Smith
family Graves still in the backyard for
when Rick had them all buried their
alternate selves in season 6 the final
shot shows that they were banned from a
bar for partying too hard we see some
receipts that they pinned up for
expensive tabs with either no tip or
just a very low tip that's well below
20% a post-edit sequence shows this
piece of Rick is trapped in like Jerry's
memories there's a field trip to what
looks like the Space Shuttle Endeavor at
the California Science Center in Los
Angeles but in Jerry's stupid memory
it's just the USS spaceship and Jerry
also tells his friend of course it can
it's a space shuttles he TOS space
shuttles like plural and he remembers
this museum is having stuff about Thomas
Jefferson even though there would be no
Jefferson exhibit at a California
Science Center or even in the
Smithsonian Air and Space Museum or
wherever this is supposed to be Jerry
apparently remembers all machine parts
it's only Springs and gears big ones
Rick is searching for Tech everywhere he
goes into what looks like Homer Simpsons
work space at the Springfield nuclear
plant sector 7g and then so Rick just
kind of resigns to his fate of turning
all these gears and springs into lawn
art you notice one of them incorporates
The Rake that started this all subscribe
to all three channels in new rockstars
Network you can support us by grabbing
some merch at nerd. shop big thanks to
Jordan moris for helping me write this
breakdown follow me on all social
platforms at eaos follow new rockstars
And subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching
bye
[Music]
n